yeah welcome to this video I'm the only
thing I have very loud sound effects I
need to I need to get you to reduce it a
bit maybe here it's really loud alright
so we have a problem zone no the Benoni
and this should be seven wow this is so
very uncommon to not feel chatter okay I
went for the principled way to play with
f4 can also choose some more restrained
ways to play that but a 4 is certainly a
logical enough way to go yeah probably
is preparing Bishop f6 to activate the
bishop Wow
yeah some very committal move weakening
of the light squares considerably
now is oh but what are you playing
besides recapturing I don't really seem
Oh hard to believe that he could make a
yeah one sec out of this okay but take
and just 23 yeah or is there something
better this shouldn't be shouldn't be
bad rating displacing this rook
yeah 23 and some normal or Quincy to
attacking not quite sure how to exploit
this weaknesses in the best possible way
c to not show ya jee successor again the
strange move weakening more okay this
was their gym
what I'd like to do is I want to use the
house the rock and also try to reroute
this Bishop to see three because the
long diagonal is sign is weakened now so
if possible nitey for and bishops III d
5 is hanging this is something to to
consider
michael g for now why do you go come on
this is also the move I mean just done
taking the space it's got very little
active plane
I only have the slightly exposed King
now need to watch watch my king position
and d5 is strong on the one hand because
it gives support give support to e6 and
so on but it's also slightly weak I'd
like to play Bishop c3 now I'll be
already too badly to be cautious with
their form
okay let's double on the phone
hmm
just strengthening the position a bit
and let's see just night g3 maybe he has
played age six and weakened c6
check
the ship's c3 is is good yeah yep cannot
take F for KD 5 is not hanging because
g6 is attacked so I can play a 5 and
freeze the whole structure
okay I need to improve further Knight d2
to see for its 11 way to do that
it's always tied to the d6 bond
yeah so my bad and game or on g5g five
results in my bed oh come on g5
36 s hanging so he's um it's not easy to
learn to move
check
and I guess yeah he needs to take you
now on f5 hard to believe that you can
allow f6 check check
time warning check check check check
check check
and what the hell it check I know is
this God's terrible like him
unbelievable czech black for fits on
time yeah yeah no I don't know it
probably he just had a connection issue
he always check sometimes strange just
when it counts at the ND as the some
connection hiccups occur you know yeah
it was it was a very good position all
along i guess here yeah i only have
stock fish at the moment he had an
engine I need to switch it to Denis but
it's funny stockfish gives this position
as equal which is a complete joke like
it on now I now it switches okay because
why this is an excellent kind of shape
yet probably probably am cleared Vantage
it's not even slightly so okay under
here this is some very tough to defend
oh here's here 96 is good oh I didn't
see that 96 96 and um a 96 Queenie five
no okay yeah thanks for watching